president biden and the first lady
visited the world war ii memorial in
washington a short time ago to honor the
2 400 americans killed at pearl harbor
less than a year before the president
was born pearl harbor veterans gather in
hawaii this morning to mark the 80th
anniversary of the attack that brought
the u.s into world war ii only a few of
the survivors from that terrible day are
still with us john dickerson looks at
how our memories of pearl harbor have
changed across generations
december 7
1941
a date which will live
in infamy they are some of the most
famous words ever uttered by an american
president
the sneak attack on pearl harbor was so
brazen so devastating the japanese
treachery would never be forgotten but
always will our whole nation remember
the character of the onslaught against
us
before america had been torn over the
war in europe let your fighter on battle
yes fight no no yes if my country calls
yes with one military stroke japan has
done what roosevelt could not do unify a
deeply divided nation america shaped a
bold confident new identity out of
stories of heroism from that day and
every year on december 7th the country
paused to remember the moment that
brought its people together
it was ships of shooting and guns going
off
bombs going off it took over 20 years to
complete a memorial honoring the nearly
one thousand sailors interred inside the
uss arizona
[Music]
for the 25th anniversary 1800 survivors
traveled to honolulu but another pacific
war shadowed the commemoration
the war in vietnam sapped the feeling
that the nation that had avenged pearl
harbor could work its will in the world
by the 1970s japanese tourists visited
the beaches of hawaii evidence of a
repaired relationship but even decades
later many survivors weren't ready to
move on still prejudiced let's put it
that way i guess i know we got good
relations and all that and we should
forget
bygones but i'll never forget that sneak
attack at the 50th anniversary a
president who had been spurred to serve
because of the attack spoke of
forgiveness
but also used the event to reiterate
america's role in the world we crushed
totalitarianism
and when that was done
we helped our enemies give birth to
democracy
and used pearl harbor's lessons to rally
the country against a new enemy the
stand against aggression in the persian
gulf
we affirmed the values cherished by the
heroes
of the harbor but conjuring a bygone
unity could not unite the country
25 years later fdr's warning had all but
disappeared with the first ever
visitation by a japanese prime minister
we
must never repeat the horrors of war
where one president had promised an
unending recollection of deceit 75 years
later his successor took another step in
making the commemoration one of
reconciliation wars can end the most
bitter of adversaries can become the
strongest of allies
long after those heroes pass we will
endeavor to continue on with that spirit
of those heroes we'll be right back